ah Shakira fait encore des siennes voir
un peu de Shakira Waka Waka
et elle était avec un footballeur
célèbre
et en fait bon ça fait quand même un an
que elle pilote vraiment
systématiquement son ex alors avec des
petites piques comme ça ça me rappelle
un peu ma vie et tout ça pour vous dire
que Shakira
elle a il parait
sur un dos et pas de petit dos c'est pas
de la
gros gros dos on vous a fait un petit
vidéo regardez
ce sont les leçons que j'ai apprises
auprès d'autres femmes et que j'ai écrit
pour elle et que j'ai chanté
parce que seule une femme peut aimer
jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit déchirée
[Applaudissements]
avec l'honnêteté la plus brutale
danser en extase et pleurer d'émotion
seule une femme peut faire ça
[Applaudissements]
femme de l'année et c'est un peu
l'étendard des des femmes des femmes
trompées on va pas se mentir est-ce que
la raison de faire ça
et du sentiment purge je trouve que son
expression est magnifique voilà elle
parle au nom de toutes les femmes elle
est convaincue elle est imprégnée elle
est habité bravo à Shakira
que les femmes qui peuvent dire les
hommes ont des sentiments aussi il faut
arrêter un peu ce cinéma
il faut rétablir une vérité si des
femmes trompent c'est quand même bien
qu'il y a des femmes qui te proposent
aussi mais bien évidemment mais beaucoup
moins ça n'a rien à voir
c'est pas dans l'ADN c'est qu'en fait
c'est en fait c'est que l'animal c'est
l'animal voilà il a besoin de chasser
mon excuses
en fait si en fait parce que
je vais donc arrêter de m'enfoncer
quand même dessus mais que quoi qu'il
arrive je trouve que lui aussi s'est
affiché avec la nouvelle nana etc donc
elle en met une couche et je pense
qu'elle s'est fait humilier qu'elle a
été trompée et très humiliée et que du
coup elle a envie aussi de voilà de de
on peut le comprendre que soit toujours
en train
de deuil c'est que chacun quand une fois
que c'est pareil c'était acté elle était
d'accord on se séparé et il s'était mis
d'accord a pas de contrat par avocat
interposé pour respecter un an de
célibataire
même si ils faisaient en scred c'est lui
la rompu le pacte c'est-à-dire qu'il
s'affichait avec une autre fille avant
que elle montre qu'elle avait un nouveau
mec et du coup c'est ça qui a tout
déclencheur
on va en parler dans dans un instant
quand même elle a de quoi être content
parce que elle a quand même fait 600
millions d'écoute avec son dernier album
là ça se passe bien quand même et 540
millions de vues en 3 mois sur Youtube
qui est porteur parce que c'est aussi
grâce à l'histoire derrière la chanson
que ça a eu autant de vues et donc elle
surfe un petit peu là-dessus mais
néanmoins elle a dû être très
traumatisée par cet humiliation et même
vis-à-vis de ses enfants parce qu'il y a
vous rappelez il y avait la belle-mère
qui avait caché l'infidélité etc donc
même par rapport à la famille donc voilà
elle est traumatisée clairement est-ce
que vos parents des fois vous ont
couvert vous non pas fait de conneries
exactement
petit meurtre en famille
donc Shakira est allé à ce Grand Prix
extraordinaire
il y avait un parterre de star c'est
exactement incroyable et est à Miami et
il y avait Tom Cruise et visiblement et
visiblement visiblement les deux
je peux vous dire que Tom Cruise il a
sorti les ailes
[Musique]
alors
nous parlons bien sûr aux conditionnel
si chacun ne regarde qu'elle fasse pas
un procès tout de suite mais cette
idylle
ou pas parce que là c'est deux personnes
qui discutent dès que ça discute la
spécule ça peut-être qu'ils discute
cette spécule spéculation que Tom Cruise
depuis son divorce en 2012 s'affiche
comme ça si je puis dire par longuement
il y a eu un tête-à-tête très long donc
c'est sujet à toutes les interfacements
donc cause a quand même le vent en poupe
Top Gun
sur le formulerie
je pense que sur ça parce que quand on a
été trompé on se dit avec qui je
pourrais sortir pour les boules à
mon ex de plus i level genre que lui
c'est compliqué de trouver aussi le son
mec il était quand même assez un beau
mec il est connu il est footballeur il
avait de l'argent donc c'est compliqué
de trouver encore au dessus mais Tom
Cruise elle a trouvé pas mal mais
honnêtement
elle a dit que c'est un pote mais mais
voilà voilà
le dossier à éviter absolument parce que
il a mis au tapis toutes ces meufs il a
traumatisé Nicole Kidman il a traumatisé
katieuls s'il voit plus sa fille il est
scientologue donc franchement c'est leur
coller le seum à son ex c'est le mec à
éviter
les acteurs américains et ça elle peut
nous en parler c'est que quand ils sont
dans leur film les mecs ils sont ils
sont chargés à testostérone ils sont
secs et tout dès qu'ils finissent le
film donc
il se relâche c'est pas tellement voyagé
Top Gun c'est après il a pris il a
presque 60 ans je crois oui là
c'est incroyable c'est un des seuls
c'est une légende vivante faut voilà
malgré tout ce qui a dit Sophie qui est
vrai c'est une légende vivante il fait
toutes ces cascades des trucs incroyable
à éviter je pense pas pour une meufs
il y a des gens on est avec lui
j'ai couché avec Tom Cruise ça le fait
alors surtout si vous le faites comme ça
ça je peux vous dire que c'est super
moderne viscobu je me suis tapé d'un
coup allez